the intern was like I think he's
bleeding out and literally it was like a
waterfall of blood just coming out
through the pelvis what's the craziest
thing you've seen in the ER few people
came in through the ambulance Bay and
they were Smurfs blue I was like what
was like that's interesting I was like
what's that about a guy with a thing you
used for guacamole I guess so like grind
it and know what that thing's called
he put that up his rectum and we see
people sticking stuff up their butts
maybe every once every couple months
what's the worst smell you've
experienced I don't know if you want to
hear this but I guess bloody diarrhea
does that count
you know it's so hard because when you
do it every day like you're used to it I
recently smelled a really pungent vomit
I've smelled Vaman before but I don't
know why this time it just really hit me
what still grosses you out
body odor still really bothers me so
when I get those patients that kind just
like throw in a mask and I'm like oh I'm
sorry like I'm coughing not feeling well
but it's really because they smell
really bad
so I don't get grossed out by like
things but when I hear the story though
of how some people get hurt that grosses
me out has an incident ever freaked you
out
I remember I passed by a broom and one
patient actually was like already like
somewhat restrained but like had like
monster strength and just like came out
of like he like lifted the whole
structure up I was like is that real
there was a guy that came in one time
and I unwrapped his foot and there was
magnets all over his foot and it was my
job
lucky me to go and clean up the maggots
and the maggots pretty much a like down
to the bone how often do you have to
look up a diagnosis every day I mean
things are changing all the time you see
a lot of the same things all the time
and then like once in a blue moon you'll
get up you'll get something that leaky
you don't know at all the other doctors
don't actually talked amongst each other
and ask each other like oh there's what
do you think this is and like if they
bounce off of each other definitely when
I first started out I was like oh yeah I
just don't know what you're talking
about I'm just gonna go
we were just to get your medication yeah
what's the most rare condition or
disease you've seen
she had this fainting condition we had
to google it and it was real it was a
real thing and I had never seen it but
she had something that said like I
always think this is normal for me like
I faint and you know like this happens
all the time
what's with the baby like six months ago
and he had this condition like where his
heart just wasn't working properly and
he was gonna need like a heart
transplant at six months to survive we
coated him for a while and then we we
sent him to another hospital I don't
know I don't know what happens him after
that but that was probably one of those
rare conditions I've seen in the ER next
one
do you've any become numb to trauma one
of the things that actually like a lot
of us have tried to do is that if a
patient passes will actually pause at
the end of the trauma and actually have
a moment of silence there just honor the
patient that makes you more conscious of
like what you're doing and it's just not
just another person coming through the
door when the patient first comes you
kind of have to be numb to just get
through the day and get through whatever
you need to get through but then once
all it's done and you're like oh my gosh
like I can't believe that just happened
to somebody anything can happen to
anyone anytime so we have that
appreciation for life after each shift
and we talk to each other about it you
know what I call it though like I really
think your nurses are a
jack-of-all-trades
and that's why I'm like I'm so like
proud to be an ER nurse in particular
because I think we do so many different
things so I mean I love it
[Music]